boeing says the FAA approval for new
safety updates to its software on the
737 max jets could come as early as next
week and this is important
Boeing also says a previously optional
safety feature will become standard
after two crashes of max jets that
killed 346 people investigators this
morning are still trying to determine
why the max fleet was certified to fly
in the first place our transportation
correspondent Kris Van Cleave is here in
New York with us good morning good
morning and there are some big questions
here we're also learning overnight
Ethiopian Airlines is pushing back
against reports questioning its safety
culture and pilot training two
complaints were filed with the FAA back
in 2015 but the airline says today they
operate the highest they operate with
the highest global standards of quality
and safety this as the focus is
increasingly turning towards Boeing
which may be the subject of a criminal
investigation sources tell CBS News
Boeing has been subpoenaed by the
Department of Justice's fraud unit DOJ
is requiring the company to retain
documents records and data related to
the Boeing 737 Max's approval process
the max fleet has been grounded for more
than a week as investigators try to
determine what led to two deadly crashes
our entire team stands behind the
quality and the safety of the aircraft
we design produce and support Boeing
says it is making changes to its
software on the max the company
announced it would now make standard an
indicator light that warns pilots of a
sensor malfunction that could cause it's
anti stall system to activate
unnecessarily investigators believe that
anti-stall system new on the 737 max
triggered on Lion Air flight 610
repeatedly forcing down the nose of the
plane leading to last October's crash
the previously optional indicator light
was not installed on the lion air 737
max that crashed or the Ethiopian flight
that went down last week a US airline
source says that feature would cost
roughly eighty thousand dollars extra on
a plane with a list price of about a
hundred and twenty million dollars this
problem should not have been that hard
to diagnose the FAA s former director of
accident investigations jeff gazette ii
says whether or not the lion air pilots
had
access to that safety feature they
should have been trained to handle the
issue the culture it seems of this
airline in not aggressively handling the
maintenance issues that were recorded as
well as the in-flight non normal
situations tells me that there's
something amiss with the system's safety
of Lion Airlines the Department of
Defense will also be reviewing all of
its Boeing aircraft and its training
practices for its crew that includes Air
Force one this is out of an abundance of
caution of course we all want to know
why was this blinking light that safety
feature not automatically a part of the
plane so this has been an available
feature on the 737 since the late 90s
boeing told me it was never particularly
a best-seller american airlines has had
it in all of their 737 since the 90s
what changed was the importance of these
sensors and they're linked to this anti
stall system which is brand new to the
max and you know it certainly sounds
like in hindsight boeing failed to
appreciate the importance of those
angle-of-attack sensors the the
importance that both of them be linked
to the anti stall system and that the
pilots have a clear understanding of
what's going on with those two sensors
they became optional two really
important in the course of this update
but in the meantime I keep thinking
about over 300 people lost their lives
seemingly now with what we're seeing now
when you see the the plane go up and
down that way you know how terrifying
that must have been for them I don't
understand why safety features are
optional to begin with it says here that
Boeing charges extra for a backup fire
extinguisher in the back yes so then
there's there are mandatory required
safety features and then just like when
you buy a car if you want to go up a
level those things cost more money Japan
for example requires more fire
extinguishers so those airlines get
charged more for fires difference
between a luxury like leather seats
absolutely upright absolutely we all
want that light yeah thank you good to
see you in person thanks for having my
screen a view at the table